The Joe Rogan Experience this bare
knuckle boxing thing has been
fascinating to watch man because it's
like someone designed the perfect sport
for you you know what I mean yes like
you are you are pretty well suited for
that and it's I find it so fascinating
because there's uh there's a certain and
I really wanted to ask you about this
because there's a certain something that
applies to Bare knuckle fighting that
just it it it's like there's a pain and
there's a danger and there's a wildness
of it that even some very great Fighters
they get to a certain they're in there
and they're like I don't like this
they're too used to gloves they're too
used to whatever they're used to they
don't want that experience once they
find it once they're in there but you
seem to thrive on it
you know it's just a real fight to me
um even though I mean I still go to the
gym and I do MMA with the guys like I'm
I love boxing so much though it's it's
my forte it's like what I'm good at
um because I'm I'm cool to take a punch
get hit that's fine I'll take a hit to
land a better one on you and
um in bare knuckle I mean
there's a lot of opportunity to fight
guys who
I mean I did fight Julian Lane who had
experience in it yeah he had nine fights
in it yeah when we fought and then I
fought two guys who hadn't done it yet
so you know
um but it's it's just like like let's
talk about those two guys like first of
all Michael Venom page that guy is super
talented yeah I mean he's extraordinary
when you watch him fight in MMA and he's
a guy that I kind of predicted one day I
was like the one skill that's that you
don't see a lot of in MMA is this crazy
Blitz Point fighting style because those
guys can cover crazy distances those are
those really good point Fighters and he
was a really good point fighter and um
he was the first guy that kind of shoot
showed how that style could apply in MMA
he's so Elusive and so hard to hit
and um you know you just put it on him
to well it was different you know it was
it's different it was boxing yeah I mean
he beat a couple guys boxing yeah um but
it's um I mean because he's good MMA
after I beat him I thought you know
maybe they'll try to make that fight
happen in MMA now but I do feel like I
would overpower him grappling wise
um but his legs are very dangerous I
mean that last guy he thought he kicked
him in the leg and it was over yeah he's
very dangerous
um that not the knockout of cyborg was
[__] crazy yeah that was good poking
ball yeah it's crazy I mean he caved his
forehead in with his legs that's what
I'm saying his legs are dangerous it's
interesting to me to want you know I'm
hungry for fights I want to fight all
these [__] well I think with a
god like that it's funny I was watching
style Bender was on Andrew Schultz's
podcast and they were talking about him
boxing some days like boxing is too
limited it's too limited to fight you
think about a guy like him who apply
eyes this full wild range of things
especially with Michael Venom page
because he's so good at closing distance
and kicking you and kneeing you and that
the knee the timing of that knee that
mean magnificent right yeah and when you
take all that away and you only have
these it's a big difference yeah it's a
gigantic difference yeah it's it's so
interesting I have the same difference
and I like it I like it fits me um I
mean I did boxing
um I had one pro boxing match I'm still
owing one as a professional boxer but
then I did that triller thing in the
triangle and I fought uh Michael seals
who was 27 and 3 in a mixed boxing match
with a turtle back MMA gloves and um you
know I won I mean I just put the
pressure on him with a turtle back MMA
gloves Turtle back or like the training
MMA oh oh okay but it was it was like
while Metallica was playing oh yeah I
heard it also they're like kind of big
MMA glass he was 27-3 as a professional
boxer he drops me uh
like once they counted it once he
dropped me another time I got hit in the
back of the head and the ref saw it and
I went down a little bit but I got right
back up so what is the biggest
difference about bare knuckle for you I
I've learned though so like when I
followed Julian Lane his little [__]
head hurt my hands because a lot of time
with boxing gloves on your hands are
like open and you try to close it at the
right time but
you know it if you do that bare knuckle
because you know how if you're squeezing
your fists it's a little harder to move
you're kind of tense but in bare knuckle
you have to learn how to move while
you're tense and keep your hands close
because with gloves you can block a shot
like this but in bare knuckle you gotta
be closed up tight and squeezing your
fist so hard so that when you hit them
in the head you're you don't destroy
your hand yeah there's like there's
three levels of vulnerability and the
level number one is like you would see a
lot of the like the glory guys they keep
their hands in a shell like Alistair
overeating or you know like bought her
heart those guys would shell up they
shell up but they have those big ass
gloves and you see that when they come
to MMA some of those shots sneak through
yes but then bare knuckle it's it's
another level of sneaking through
it's a totally different it's it's
really interesting to watch a really
good fighter like Luke rockhold you know
and you and you know Luke rockhold is
very skillful he's a very skillful guy
and when you were putting it on him I
was like this is a totally different
thing and you are like uniquely suited
for this totally different thing
thank you it's different than regular
boxing men and women remember in Paulie
malinaji fought uh artem lobov
well Polly I mean he's a scrawny dude
yeah
and lobov was just a little dog he's a
dog yeah it was a good fight to be
honest but the jabbing and moving that
Paulie did didn't work for him and Luke
I don't know you know that's kind of
what we were talking about when you
brought up Luke we were talking about I
was talking about the type fists and
like how bare knuckle is different and
it's like I figured out how to utilize
the bare knuckle I mean I knocked his
teeth out I hit him by the time I caught
him and then he was like I'm not trying
to get hit like that again it was a
matter of time the Gap was closing it
takes a second he hit me too and I told
him I bet it um I haven't talked to him
about it or asked him because I don't
um I mean you know he lost or whatever
so I don't talk to losers but I try to
do what winners do man I try to think
about Winners but when I hit him with
that shot and he didn't want to get hit
again
um he had hit me I got a little nod on
my face right there but I took it and I
bet it hurt him I bet it hurt his hand I
told told him before the fight you're
gonna punch me in the head it's gonna be
the hardest thing you ever hit and then
I'm gonna I'm gonna head butt you in
your hands and I'm gonna punch you in
your face and you're gonna quit and
that's what he did
wow yeah it's good stuff man it's a
different thing man it's a different
thing I think I can do it in any gloves
though any I could fight in the UFC I
have a mindset and I fight with these
guys I do MMA I see your belt on the
wall in there when I went and did the
cold plunge you're it's like a red belt
or a black belt with red stripes that's
not your belt no no it's Jean-Jacques
Machado when he when he got his Coral
belt he gave some of them out to some of
us man dudes like that you know Coral
Bell stuff I'm I'm going to chase back
my my black belt I'm a purple belt for a
stripe for years now could have been had
my brown belt I got great Jiu Jitsu I
trained with some of the best Jiu Jitsu
practitioners I just choose to sprawl
and brawl I like to punch people I think
it's the best off button I enjoy it and
it's exciting and it's an entertainment
business right so
um
you know uh
[__] lost my there's something to be
said for that for sure I mean look
people love to watch you fight
thank you I appreciate it I was always a
giant fan oh that's what I was my point
was yeah you had wild I will fight
anyone anywhere I would love to please
give me opportunities I want to show and
be I want to be a [__] Coral belt in
my own right in my own way and people
know when Mike Perry walks down the
street it's like that's what the baddest
[__] that ever lived dude Mike
Perry they're going to talk about me
just like they did Mike Tyson I feel
like Mike Tyson I feel
different I'm I'm better
what what changed in you like how how
did you come into your own because you
were always a really good fighter but it
seems like over the last few years
you're on a completely different I have
a family I love them so much and
you know I'm a I'm a human I [__] up I
make mistakes and [__] but you know I
know I don't give up I keep going and I
push and I took you know David Goggins
type [__] you know it's like I stopped
making [__] excuses and
[__] was like you know cause I'm hurt
all the time I'm always [__] hurt I
don't care I'm like all right [__] it I
gotta wake up every day and feel this
[__] you can't [__] hurt me because
I'm I'm in enough pain I take anything
you got and give it back
that's fighting and I got and I do it
for
you know I do it for fighting I love
fighting it's like that's my [__] that's
even though it hurts it [__] my face
up I've hate it's a love-hate
relationship
my family can hurt my feelings too so
it's all emotional feelings and if you
tell yourself just
who cares like just no one cares about
your problems or anything so just handle
your business